I found you this morning when I was on
break I thought you were funny if a
little insane
I quickly forgot you and gone on with my
day
then there you were back in my mind
again I figured I'd find you to see what
you've done
very impressive looks like you have fun
I want to say thank you for brightening
my day I hope that I do just the same
for you
[Music]
for you and I know that you're busy but
I hope you find the time to reply
I've spent my whole evening sitting
watching you but there's nothing left
now could you make something you I find
with so much in common
Oh eeeh can it be I feel I know you you
don't know me I know it sounds crazy but
I think if we met spend time together
you would end up friends and although
it's unlikely think I'll be fine these
unlikely things happen all the time I
love that from you
I love that from you
and I know that you're busy but I hope
you find the time to reply it's been so
long and I haven't heard back
I tell you how long but I think I lost
track is it really so hard to write just
a sentence - I've just seen your latest
and it was ok but it wasn't quite you
seems like you've changed you still
enjoying the things that you do you say
that you are but it doesn't ring true I
went back to see you the way that you
were thought it might cheer me up
I just didn't work I thought you should
know that I think that I'm done
just not for me now but I've had fun
watching you
[Music]
watching you and I know that you're busy
so don't worry you don't have to reply
[Music]
that song has emotions in it weird
thanks for watching and if you like that
song I'm gonna put it on Bandcamp so you
can download it either for free or you
can buy it if you'd like to support me
my band camp is Charlie McDonnell Van
Camp calm I think we're gonna put the
link down in the description how about
it dudes okay bye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool